first of all start with these reports
that Russia is fighting off what it's
calling a terrorist attack in the
southern France region a bordering
Ukraine what do you know about what's
going on here it's a bit of breaking
news SJ really the Russians claims that
Ukrainian terrorist activity trying to
Target grants which is away from the uh
the Ukrainian border caused the
ukrainians deny this what's been
interesting about this story the Russian
media local media have been predicting
that there might be an attack for the
last few days which is a bit suspicious
also social media images and the videos
coming from it by experts are looking at
them saying they're massively stage
managed so it's not entirely clear where
there's a false flag operation done by
Russia for Russia's needs or what the
truth is we'll just have to get back to
viewers once it becomes clear of what
the facts are okay uh well we're in the
early stages of that story meanwhile
over the Border in Ukraine what's
happening on the ground there well back
Motors they're clearly one of the big
stories um inevitably the fighting here
for the last six months Russia's
Russia's been attacking the city now
they've been described as storming the
city they are making small advances but
it's very very slow but at massive cost
um it's worth pointing out again that
back moot isn't militarily a significant
but of course it's become symbolically
very important for both parties
President zielinski yesterday described
it as very difficult there's been a
Ukrainian MP now coming out saying that
almost certainly the Ukrainian forces
will have to withdraw at some time
um soon because the risk of encirclement
and if you encircle you've either got to
withdraw or you've got to fight it out
if you withdraw then you hand Putin a
tactical Victory and if you stay on
fight uh almost certainly Ukraine loses
some very experienced battle-hardened
soldiers which could prove critical in
the days and weeks ahead can we talk
about happenings at volada Ukraine
reporting big Russian losses there
what's the truth of the matter there
again now bullardara the fighting's been
going fiercely but that is more more
militarily significant it's on some High
Ground there are some rail links there's
some Road Links all part of the resupply
routes for for the fighting for the last
three weeks Russia has been throwing the
proverbial kitchen sink at it Ukraine
claims that over 130 tanks have been
lost at our personnel carriers over that
time in context Russia can only play
replace these tanks at 20 a month so
that's six months worth of Tanks over a
three week period in one attack and the
challenge of course when the Russians
lose the hardware they just keep
throwing their inventory at this attack
and the challenge there is they throw
the Infantry at the attack they get
defeated they wheel in a whole load more
new conscripts or even less experienced
and they repeat the whole process again
the tragic of this is there's been huge
casualties Ukraine has claimed as you
said 150 000 now these figures are
always disputed and that's probably on
the high side but the real tragedy here
is because Putin is controlling the
messaging into Russia the domestic
Russians the Russian population will
have no idea of the scale and the tragic
consequences this war on the Russian
soldiers okay her Sean thank you Sean
Bell with the latest there on Ukraine
thank you